*playful music* (slap pity tap tap slapping tap tap tap tap)
(Markimoo is confused) Huh?
*music continues* *mouse clicking sounds*
*silence*
*Gasps*
*GASPS AGAIN*
*MORE GASPS*
Guys! I just hit 17 million
sub... scribers...
Many singing: Happy birthday to WaDe!
Happy birthday to wAdE! (not pictured a very sad mark)
Happy birthday
Mark: Guys...
Others singing: dear WaAAaDe!
Mark: Guys, guys, I get it with...
Others singing: Happy birthday!
Mark, quietly: but, me...
Others singing: to WADE!
Others: *cheering*
Mark: Guys, I feel like you're not listeninnnggg to meeee                ༼ つ ಥ_ಥ ༽つ
Ethan: Now blow out the candle!
*foof*
Others: *laughter, clapping, cheers*
Ethan: Happy birthday, Wade!  Bob: Happy birthday, Wade!  *mark is internally screaming and falling apart*
*Cheerful guitar music, while a wild Markimoo is in the background, now externally screaming* ( mark is now going to kill wade)